لصالح الغاء ما يعرف ببند المحوريه الذي
يعد جزءا من التغييرات القضائيه التي تسعى
حكومه نتنياهو لاقرارها وصوت لصالح
المشروع 64 صوتا مقابل مقاطعه معارضه في
نتيجه انهيار محاولات التوصل الى التسويه
بين الطرفين في الاثناء تتالت التحذيرات
من انعكاسات هذه التطورات على وحده مؤسسه
الدوله وبقائها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اين ياخذ تصويت
الكنيست لصالح بند جديد في مشاريع قوانين
حكومه نتنياهو الخلاف بشان التغييرات
القضائيه وما يدور حولها من مواقف وردود
شملت المؤسستين العسكريه والامنيه وكيف
نقرا تمسك طرفي الخلاف بموقفهما وفشلهما
لحد الان في الذهاب نحو الحوار والسعي من
خلاله للتوسل لحل الوسط يتجاوز الازمه
واخفاق كل مبادرات الوساطه التي صدر اهمها
عن الرئاسه الاسرائيليه ونقابه العمل
والى اين تذهب الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه
في اسرائيل بالنظر الى اقتراب الاستقطاب
الحاد بين الحكم والمعارضه لنقطه الله
عوده وهل في الاحتمالات القائمه ما يضع
بقاء الدوله على المحك وكيف سيتفاعل
المحيطان الاقليمي والدولي مع كل هذا
[موسيقى]
اذا لم تنجح الوسطات لم تنجح حتى محاولات
وزير الامن
للدفع نحو تعديل احادي الجانب لتخفيف
الخلاف بشان التغييرات القضائيه مضت حكومه
نتنياهو نحو التصويت رغم امتناع المعارضه
وكان لها ما اردت ما يعرف بقوه كابلات
التي تنظم الاحتجاجات ضد التغييرات
القضائيه قالت في بيان لها حكومه الخراب
صوتت لسحق دوله اسرائيل
وسنقاتل تلك الحكومه حتى النهايه لتعود
دولتنا ديمقراطيه من جديد زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه
بدوره قال لن نستسلم ولن يقرر المتطرفون
شكل الدوله في اسرائيل
رئيس الهستروت ارنون بن دافيد قال ساجتمع
مع مسؤولين نقابيين لمناقشه امكانيه اعلان
اضراب عام بعد ما صوتت عليه الكنيست
معركه حاميه الوطيس يتردد صداها حتى داخل
الحكومه نفسها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار قال هذه ليست سوى
البدايه واسرائيل باتت اكثر ديمقراطيه
ويهوديه اليوم بينما هدد وزراء اخرون
يتقدمهم وزير القضاء يا ريف ليفن باسقاط
الحكومه في حال عدم التوصل مستقبلا
لتفهمات
خارجيا قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كاران جابر ان الولايات المتحده تاسفوا
لنتيجه التصويت وتحث الحكومه على التوصل
لتوافق واسع عبر الحوار
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشتي هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عامه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن ام الفحم الدكتور
مهند مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن واشنطن الدكتور خليل الاعلاني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا
بكم جميعا فيما وراء الخبر وابدا معك
دكتور مهند مصطفى
اذا تحقق لنتنياهو ما اراد رغم كل ما
شاهدناه خلال الاشهر الماضيه رغم كل
الاحتجاجات لم يتم
التوصل لاي تفاهم او تسويه ورغم العصيان
حتى في المؤسسه العسكريه هل يمكن القول ان
نتنياهو رابح المعركه ام هي مجرد الجوله
الاولى فيها
الجوله الاولى ولكن هذه الجوله سيكون لها
ثمن باهض على اسرائيل
على المستويات العسكريه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه والتكتل الاجتماعي الداخلي في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي نتنياهو بالنهايه ذهب
الى اكرار بند المعقوليه لانه كان يعلم
انه اذا الغى هذا البند او اجله فان
حكومته كانت سوف تسقط لان اليمين المتطرف
في داخل هذه الحكومه واحده من الاجندات
الهامه لديه وتغيير السلطه القضائيه لان
اليمين يعلم ان السلطه القضائيه هي واحده
من العقبات التي تقف امامه في بعض الاحيان
امام مشروعه من اجل تهويد دوله اسرائيل
واحتلالها التداعيات لهذا التغيير
الدستوري يتداعيات عميقه جدا ليس فقط من
الناحيه العسكريه والامنيه ولكن من
الناحيه الاجتماعيه على تكتل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي والمجتمع الاسرائيلي كان كل
الوقت يتم تكتله من خلال وجود مؤسسه
سياسيه
لانه راس حكومه خراب وانه كذاب وما الى
ذلك هذه امور ربما يعني بصراحه لم نتوقعها
بحق رئيس حكومه اسرائيل كنا نسمعها كثيرا
في السابق من اطراف اخرى ولكن ليست من
اطراف داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولكن ما
الذي يعنيه فعليا هذا الكلام هل هي مجرد
معركه سياسيه يعني محتدمه ستنتهي مع مرور
بمرور الوقت وسيتم التوصل للتفاهمات ام
الامر اعمق
يعني
يتواصل ويتعلق بشيء له اساس بجوهر اسرائيل
ومستقبلها
له اعمق من ذلك بكثير وليست صدفه ان غانتس
زعيم احد زعماء المعارضه وصف الذي يجري
هذا الانهيار الداخلي في اسرائيل بانه
خراب الهيكل الثالث انا برايي جوهر ما
يجري هو بالضبط ما تنبا به كثير من
الحكماء منذ سنوات بان الاحتلال خلق
الاستيطان والاستيطان خلق نظام الابرتايد
العنصري ونظام الابرتايد العنصري انتج
الفاشيه في اسرائيل والذي نراه اليوم
تحالف عميق بين الفاشيه الصهيونيه
اليهوديه المتطرفه المتعصبه الاصوليه مع
اللصوص والمحتالين في هذه الحكومه يعني
عندما لماذا يريد تخريب القضاء لانهم
يريدوا ان يهربوا من المحاكمه سواء
نتنياهو المتهم بالفساد او درعي الذي
يريدون ان يعيدونه الى ان يعيدوه الى
الحكومه وهو ايضا متهم بالفساد يعني شيء
مذهل تحالف الفساد واللصوصيه مع الفاشيه
الصهيونيه المتطرفه العنصريه التي احتفلت
اليوم بتمرير هذه الاجراءات التي تعني ان
النظام القضائي في اسرائيل يدمر وانهم
يسيروا فعلا بخطى حديثه نحو الديكتاتوريه
المشكله ان المعارضه عاجزه عن ان تفهم
السبب الجوهري لكل ما يجري يعني نفس
المعارضه التي تعارض نتنياهو تعزز وتقوي
تعزز وتقوي في الواقع نفس السبب الذي يؤدي
الى نمو هذه الفاشيه وهو الاحتلال
والاستيطان ولا تعارض نتنياهو في سياساته
اتجاه الشعب الفلسطيني يعني هي نفسها تشجع
ما يؤدي الى تدمير ما تريد ان يبقى
وبالتالي انا براي الازمه عميقه جدا
وسيكون لها تداعيات خطيره وابرز هذه
التداعيات الانهيار في الجيش يجب ان نتذكر
ان السكان اليهود في اسرائيل هم جيش
اسرائيل يعني اي جيش الاحتلال هو من
الاحتياط من جنود وضباط الاحتياط وهؤلاء
الذين يتمردون الان بالتالي هذا يعني تفكك
داخلي وهذا يعني ايضا انهيار اقتصادي
اليوم كل المؤشرات الاقتصاديه كانت تشير
الى تراجع كبير في البورصه الاسرائيليه
بالتالي انا اعتقد ان الازمه عميقه ولن
تحل حتى باتفاق بين المعارضه
يحكموا اسرائيل
يخاطب هؤلاء هؤلاء الجنود والضباط في
الاحتياط الان دكتور خليل العناني طبعا في
وجه كل هذا واشنطن تاسس لما حدث والسؤال
هو ما حجم هذا الاسف هل هو كافي لتاخذه
اسرائيل في الحسبان ليحدث شيء مختلف هذه
المره في داخل الحكومه
لا اعتقد ذلك على الاطلاق هناك انطباعا
داخل اسرائيل بان حكومه او اداره بايدار
ضعيفه مهتزه ولذلك هناك عدم اقتراف باي
مواقف قد تبدي هذه الاداره واخر مؤشرات
على هذا عدم الاقتراض فهو التمرين هذا
تعديل القضائي رغم اننا هناك المعارضه
وكان هناك توبيخ قبل ثلاثه اشهر من الان
قام به وطلبه والفور بوقف هذه التعداد حتى
يتم التوصل للشبه لقضم الاتفاق او الاجماع
حول تمريرها بشكل او باخر حتى لا تؤثر او
لا تتاثر بدمقراطيه الاسرائيليه التي
تعتبر بشكل او باخر نسخه امريكيه كما يرى
بيض لكن هذه الازمه مؤخرا ليس هناك رد فعل
الامريكي قوي بالعكس هناك نوع من عدم
الضغط على نتنياهو سمعنا هناك محادثه
محادثه بين تنياهو بين بايدن لم تسفر عن
شيء كما حدث الامر في السابق بل اكثر من
ذلك انه قبل اسبوع من الان التقى بيضا
بتوم من الصحف المعروف ونقل من خل وسائل
الى اسرائيل وهذا يعكس ضعف او عدم قدره
بين او عدم رغبته في المواجهه مع الجماعات
المؤيده خاص نحن نعم لطالما سمعنا عن قوه
اللوبي اليهودي صهيوني في داخل الولايات
المتحده هذه المره هل تحرك هل كان له
الصوت يذكر في الاحتجاج على هذه الخطوه
التي اتخذها نتنياهو هنا
بشكل عام هناك حتى هذه اللحظه موقف متحفظ
من هذا اللب الصهيوني ليس كتله واحده هناك
لوبي دعم طول خط وبالتالي ليس لدي مشكله
في اي تعداد قضائيه بعضهم حتى يؤيد الامير
داخل اسرائيل لكن ايضا هناك ما يسمى
بالاثار اليهودي او اليسار الامريكي اللي
هو الذي شكل او باخر يدعم وجود دوله
ليبراليه علمانيه على غرار الدوله
الامريكيه او الغرار النموذج الامريكي هذا
اليسار الامريكي الدعم الاسرائيلي وفي
موقف حرج الى حد بعيد ويضغط شكلها باخر
بوجود نوع من الضغوط الامريكيه على
اسرائيل فيما يتعلق التعديلات وقرانا
وسمعنا خلال الفتره الماضيه بوجود حاله
تزمر داخل اليسار الدعم لاسرائيل في
امريكا خاصه حزب الديمقراطي فيما يتعلق
مدينه تعديلات ويرى البعض انك قد تمثل
نهايه لاسرائيل البعض يرى ايضا ان قد تمثل
تهديد للعلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
القويه التي تعتبر عنصر رئيسي في هذه
العلاقه المستمره على مدار على الاقل سبعه
عقود وبالتالي الموقف في الموقف الصهيوني
موقفا واحدا هناك نوع من الاختلافات في
هذه المرحله
بانه قد نكون على مرحله جديده فيما يتعلق
على الاستراليه تعديلات القضائيه دكتور
مهند مصطفى لطالما باعتنا اسرائيل باعت كل
العالم في الواقع خطاب مفاده نحن دوله
ديمقراطيه نحن دوله مؤسسات وما الى ذلك
وكثيرون في الغرب صدقوا
الان ما حدث يعني الدوله الديمقرايه يفترض
انها تستطيع ان تحل مشاكلها سياسيه تتوصل
الى تفاهمات ان يكون هناك دور للنخب هذا
لم يحدث هذه المره لماذا ما الذي
لم يتحقق بسببه توصل وما الذي يمكن ان
يضره بهذه السمعه التي حاولت اسرائيل
تسويقها
اولا السبب بذلك ان اليمين الاسرائيلي
وبالذات اليمين الديني اليوم اليمين في
اسرائيل هو يمين ديني يعني حتى حتى
الليكود الذي كانت تاريخيا هو يمين علمان
الليبرالي اليوم تحول اكثر واكثر اليمين
ديني هذا اليمين يريد ان يحسم دوله
اسرائيل بمعنى يحسمها بانه يريد ان يبنيها
من جديد بما يتوافق مع توجهات الايدولوجيه
وهذا جزء من الغيور الذي اصاب اليمين في
السنوات الاخيره اسرائيل بنيت عام 1948
حسب توجهات صهيونيه علمانيه معينه التي
كان في مركزها نخب اجتماعيه بالذات النخب
الاجتماعيه الاشكنازيه والان اليمين الذي
فيه نخب جديده يريد ان يغير دوله اسرائيل
وهو غير مستعد لاي توافق حول هويه دوله
اسرائيل التي يريدها اكثر يهوديه واقل
ديمقراطيه وهذا ايضا جزء من الخطاب الشعبي
ولذلك اليمين لا يريد ان لا يريد اي توافق
يريد ان يحسم هويه دوله اسرائيل ولذلك حتى
في الساعات الاخيره عندما حاول وزير
الدفاع يوقف وحتى نتنياه نفسه قد حاول ان
يخفف من وطاه القانون او ان يؤجله كانت
هنالك معارضه شديده ليس فقط من اليمين
المتطرف حتى من داخل الكود كانت لمعارضه
لاي تاجيل او لاي تعديل للقانون لانه
بالنسبه لليمين هذه الحكومه هي فرصه
تاريخيه للجنين هذه فرصه تاريخيه لحظه
تاريخيه بنسبه لليمين لكي يحقق كل
الايديولوجيته وكل الاجندات السياسيه
والفكريه التي يؤمن بها الان ذلك سينعكس
ايضا على اسرائيل حول خطابها انها الدوله
الديمقراطيه الوحيده في الشكل الاوسط
اسرائيل حتى قبل هذه التعديلات كان فيها
اعطاب كبيره جدا في نظامها السياسي طبعا
هي ديمقراطيه لليهود يعني الفلسطينيين على
سبيل المثال في داخل اسرائيل ممن يحملون
المواطن الاسرائيليه يعانون من التمييز
والاقصاء ولكن كانت هذه لكن كان النظام
السياسي النظام ديمقراطي يدير الخلافات في
داخل المجتمع اليهودي وكانت تسوق نفسها
الدوله الديمقراطيه الوحيده الان اسرائيل
بالتصويت على هذا البند هي عمليا الذي
الذي قامت به هي الغت اي رقابه للسفر
قضائيه على السلطه التنفيذيه لانه قانون
المعقوليه بند المعقوليه ويتعلق بسلطه
وبصلاحيه المحكمه العليا بالتدخل باجراءات
وسنها الحكومه بكل نواحي الحياه وذلك
الغاء هذه الرقابه القضائيه عمليا يحول
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى حكومه ديكتاتوريه
في اسرائيل يعني هي تستطيع الان ان تشرع
اي قرار اي اجراء اي اي قرار اداري فيه
انتهاك وهذا ما كان هذا الامر
خطير وفي النهايه هو ما كان يشكو منها
الفلسطينيون في السابق الان مع هذه القوه
الجديده التي يكتسبها دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي يصبح الامر اخطر واكبر بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين في الداخل وايضا في الضفه وفي
غزه لاننا اعتدنا من نتنياهو ان دائما
يصدر ازماته
للجانب الفلسطيني هل ترى ان هذا ما سيحدث
هذه المره هل هذا كافي لكي يتخلص من حجم
الانقسام والغضب الموجود حاليا داخل
اسرائيل
انا برايي هناك خطران كبيران الان الخطر
الاول ان نتنياهو قد يلجا الى افتعال حرب
باي شكل من الاشكال كي يخمد المعارضه في
اسرائيل
ويستمر في اجراءاته القضائيه هذا احتمال
قائم يجب ان ينتبه له الجميع الامر الثاني
طبعا الان مشروعهم الاساسي هو استكمال
عمليه الضم والتهويد للضفه الغربيه وتكريس
نظام الابرتايد العنصري ولذلك انا برايي
ما يجري الان هو فرصه كبيره للنضال الوطني
الفلسطيني لكشف وتعريه اسرائيل بشكل كامل
كمنظومه عنصري التغييرات القضائيه لم تبدا
اليوم التغييرات القانونيه لم تبدا اليوم
بدات مع اقرار ما سمي بقانون القوميه الذي
يعطي حق تقرير المصير فقط لليهود وكرس
اسرائيل كمنظومه عنصريه ومنظومه
السؤال هنا متى ستفهم المعارضه وانا اشك
في ذلك انما يجري هو بالضبط السرطان سرطان
الاحتلال والعنصريه الذي يلتهم اسرائيل من
الداخل كما توقع كثيرون بالتالي هذه
التوجهات الفاشيه طبعا خطره وستحاول ان
تنفس ازمتها في الاعتداء على الشعب
الفلسطيني سواء في الاراضي المحتله او
خارج الاراضي المحتله ولذلك هذا سبب اضافي
في ظل هذا التطور اي الخطير ايضا والفرصه
العظيمه التي تنشا امامنا الان هذا سبب
اضافي لتوحيد الساحه الفلسطينيه وتوحيد كل
الطاقات الفلسطينيه في مواجهه ليس فقط
الاحتلال بل كل نظام
الصهيونيه العنصريه والاضطهاد الديني
اليهودي والسؤال هم ربما الدكتور خليل
العناني اذا ما تحقق ذلك والتههم السرطان
جسد الدوله هل ستترك واشنطن حليفها هكذا
يدوي ويمرض ويتفتت ام ستقوم بشيء مختلف
فهذه المره وتتدخل رغم العلاقه المتوتره
ورغم الضعف الذي اشرت اليه بالنسبه للرئيس
بايدن فيما يتعلق
بعلاقته مع اسرائيل هذه
انا اعتقد لابد ان نفرق بين امرين الامر
المتعلق بوجود ما يسمى بقيم مشتركه
اسرائيليه امريكيه سوف متعلق بالديمقراطيه
وبينما يتعلق بوجود اسرائيل كمصلحه
استراتيجيه امريكيه في المنطقه اعتقد ان
الجوز المتعلقه بمصالح سيظل مستمر وموجوده
وبالتالي من مصلحه امريكا وجود علاقات
استراتيجيه باعتبارها حليفا مهما في تلك
المنطقه من العالم تقوم بادوار لا تقوم
بامريكا سواء متعلق بالبعد الاستخباراتي
او الامني او الدفاعي ذلك لكن ايضا هناك
نوع من الحرج تتسبب في هذه الازمه فيما
يتعلق بدعم امريكي لدوله ديكتاتوريه في
المنطقه طبعا هذا الامر موجود تدعم دول
مختلف انحاء العالم خاصه في المنطقه
العربيه لكن ايضا في متعلق باسرائيل
الحوجه التي يتم دائما تسويقها من اجل
تقديم مساعده عسكريه تصل حوالي 4 مليار
دولار في السنه متعلق بوجود قيم مشتركه
بين الدولتين وبالتالي ما يقال عللا قد
يكون مختلف عما يقال سرا قد مشهد خلال
الفتره المقبله بوجود ضغوط امريكيه في
الساده على اسرائيل من اجل الا تمر هذه
التعديلات بشكل اكثر فدعها من الان ان
احنا نتحدث عن خطه كامله عن مجموعه حزمه
قوانين يتم ترطيبها من قبل قد يؤدي الى
تقويض الدوله اليهوديه كما كما نعلم جميعا
كما جاء خلال اخر سبعه سبعه عقود وبالتالي
قد يتم وضع ضغوط سريه حتى لا يتم او حتى
نوع من الشقاق ونوع من الاشقاق في
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه في
المستقبل القريب ولكن الدكتور
يعني يبدو انه في معركه كسر العظم هذه
الامر لم يتوقف عند هذه المرحله انت كيف
ترى الخطوات القادمه هل هناك مثلا نقاط
مفصليه تتوقعها من اطراف معينه في الفتره
القادمه
وهذا الامر سيؤدي الى تعميق اكثر واكثر
مما نراه الان في الازمه السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في داخل اسرائيل ولذلك حاله
الاحتقان الاجتماعي والسياسه في داخل
اسرائيل سوف تستمر بهذه الفتره الصيفيه
والكنيست سوف تخرج الى اجازه حتى شهر
نوفمبر ولكن هذه الفتره ستكون مليئه
بالاعتقان السياسي وهنالك ممكن ان يكون
حاله من العنف الداخلي لا اقول اقتتال
داخلي ولا اقول حرب اهليه ولكن بدايه عنف
داخلي بين من يؤيدون الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ومن يعارضونها ولذلك اسرائيل الان تتجه
نحو مرحله مفصليه في تحديد هويتها ولكن
بالاساس ان قوتها كانت موجوده قوه اسرائيل
كانت قدرتها على الحفاظ على هذا التكتل في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا التكتل الان
تم تمزيقه وهو ينعكس ايضا في داخل جيش
الاسرائيلي الذي كان
قوته مبنيه
كونه جيش الشعب جيش غير مسيس وجيش مبني
بالاساس على الاحتياط هذه الثلاث اسس لقوه
الجيش الاسرائيلي تم انتهاكها اليوم ولذلك
اسرائيل متجهه نحو مرحله جديده نحو لحظه
تاريخيه جديده سيكون فيها الاحتقان
السياسي والاجتماعي قوي جدا قد يؤدي الى
حاله من الداخل فقط دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
يعني انه يمكن الاستفاده من هذه الفرصه ان
صح وصفها بذلك كيف كيف يمكن فعلا ان سواء
فلسطينيا او من جانب الدول العربيه هل
يمكننا ان فعلا ان يكون هناك تحرك جديد
ومجدي هذه المره
نعم هناك فرصه عظيمه الان لتنفيذ ما دعونا
اليه بفرض المقاطعه والعقوبات على هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه اذا كان نفس المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يتمرد عليها ويصفها بانها
فاشيه وديكتاتوريه ومجرمه ويصف نتنياهو
بانه لص وخائن لماذا تبقى علاقات تطبيع
معه ومع مثل هذه الحكومه المكروهه حتى
داخليا انا برايي هذه الفرصه كبيره لتحطيم
كل ما بناه نتنياهو من تطبيع من اجل تصفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه هذه فرصه لعزل اسرائيل
كمنظومه ابارتايت عنصريه بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه وهذه فرصه الان لتوحيد النضال
الفلسطيني بعد ان اصبح الجميع يدرك ان ما
هو امامنا ليس لا توجد اي فرصه لحلول وسط
ما امامنا هو منظومه عنصريه اجراميه تريد
ان تفرض الضم والتهويد ولا افق الان الا
لمشروع واحد مشروع النضال والمقاومه
والكفاح واستراتيجيه وطنيه موحده لمواجهه
هذا النظام الفاشل امامنا فرصه عظيمه
وامل ان نستغلها في اجتماعنا القادم في
القاهره
اشكرك جزيلا الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي امين عام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه واشكر طبعا ايضا الدكتور مهند
مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه من ام
الفحم واشكر من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لكم على المتابعه
[موسيقى]